الان الى مدير مستشفى اريحا الحكومي
الدكتور ناصر العناني دكتور ما الذي يمكن
ان تخبرنا عنه بخصوص وصول حالات
واصابات جراءه الاقتحام الذي حصل اليوم
لمخيم عقبه جبر
يسعد مساكم اولا تم اقتحام اليوم مخيم
عقبه جبر بعد حصار لمدينه اريحا السمر
اكثر من اربعه ايام
وصل الى مستشفى الريحه اصابه متوسطه اصابه
مطاط في الراس حيث كانت قوات الجيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تعيق حركه السيارات
الاسعاف ومرور الطواقم الى مخيم عقبه جبر
هناك معلومات تفيد ان هناك حرجه جدا تم
اقتياد من قبل القوات الجيش الاحتلال
وهناك ايضا التحدث عن اصابات لم تصل لحد
الان لمستشفى اريحا وهناك الحديث يدور عن
اعتقالات عن اربع خمس اعتقالات
لشبان تتهم ملك القوات الاسرائيليه بتنفيذ
عمليات ضد اسرائيليين دكتور ناصر مصابه
برصاص حي ام برصاص مطاط
الرصاص مطاط في الراس ووضعه مستقر
مستقر في الراس
نعم ذكرت ان هناك حاله حاله اصابه
خطيره كما قلت وصفت بذلك ونقلتها القوات
الاسرائيليه الى اين
دعم هذه اذا جهات لا يعلمه الا الله يعني
هذول بياخذوهم عدد مش اول مره وليس بغريب
على قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلياح السابقه قبل شهر تم اغتيال
جرحه ثلاثه جرحه وصفت حالتهم كانت حرجه
بالاضافه الى الشهداء فهذا اعتدنا عليه مع
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي طيب عندما نتكلم
عن حصار تعاني منه الان اريحا انتم على
الصعيد الاستشفائي كيف يؤثر عليكم هذا
الوضع خاصه عندما تتطور الامور الى ما جرى
في الساعات الماضيه في في عقبه جبر
اولا عندما تقوم ريحه تقوم قوات الاحتلال
بمحاصره اريحا تمنع الدخول والخروج الى
المدينه تحيق جدا حركه مرور الطواقم
الطبيه الى داخل المدينه فهناك صعوبه جدا
في تنقل التمريض والاطباء والاطقم الفنيه
الى داخل المدينه
هذا اعتدنا عليه لكن هناك جاهزيه كامله
داخل المشفى معظم الطواقم على جائزه كامله
واتم الاستعداد حيث اعتدنا هذا ليس
الاجتياح الاول والاجتياح الاخير
اثناء الاشتباكات نعم كانت هناك في
البدايه منعت سيارات الاسعاف للدخول
باستثناء فقط سياره الهلال اما بقيه
الاسعاف فمنعت من الوصول الى داخل المخيم
تحدثت عن احتمال وجود اصابات اكبر جراء
الاقتحام المخيم هل يعني هذا ان بعض
سيارات الاسعاف لم تعد حتى الان من المخيم
ام ماذا
لكن لا ندري اذا
كانوا ام لا ساعات القليل القادمه ستكشف
لنا عن هذه الاصابات لكن هناك كما ذكرت
وذكرنا هناك اصابه حرجه جدا تم قياده من
قبل قوات الجيش الاسرائيلي
كيف عرفتم انها اصابه حرجه فقط
اولا هذه المعلومه اخذناها من
السيارات الهلال
داخل المخيم بالاضافه كان هناك بث حي
ومباشر لتلفزيون فلسطين من داخل المخيم
فضاء حرجه بسبب طلق ناري
في الصدر رصاص حيث الصدر
اذا رصاص مطاطي استخدم وايضا رصاص حي
الحاله التي وصلتك كانت بسبب رصاص مطاطي
التي وصلت الى مشفى لكن الاصابه الحرجه هي
كانت لرصاص حيث الصدر